[Music]
nobody who's ever changed anything has
pander to what people think right you
have to basically close your eyes and
your ears for the next 20 years and just
put out what you want to put out and
then you have a chance of making it
happen but the more you worry or think
or strategize around acceptance the more
unlikely you'll achieve your goal you
got your prospective
[Music]
I'm in Romania about to speak yes please
just focus trying to think about what
I'm going to speak about it's a very
international crowd it's very political
about a world leaders big stage and kind
of debating whether I want to go through
[Music]
which which angle do I want to go
through but I think the filter of what
I'm most passionate about which is
consumer behavior how how we consume
information what that leads to and more
importantly these 7,000 different
organizations are in that room you could
talk about AI you could talk about
machine learning you could talk about
Big Data but at the end of the day it's
still how does it make people think and
live and do and how do you become the
best contextual creator in the world I
think is what I think about
yeah I'm heading right back to New York
yeah it's in and out yeah
story in my life sure you're welcome
hi how are you thank you thank you yes
sir it's required but what if the
environment is very negative in fate
then you leaders it's just the game you
know we love you thank you brother sure
the advice for the people is live your
life you've only got one at bat do
something with it
thank you
[Applause]
thank you good morning morning I'm gonna
leave with a framework of why I believe
that audio should be the biggest
conversation in this conference I
believe that way too many people make
the mistake of trying to catch the next
technology wave long before it's the
actual technology wave there has been a
remarkable of money lost in the last
three or four years around VR and AR not
because it's not coming but because the
number one mistake in this collective
room is not paying attention to the
actual consumer we have ideologies
around our technology we are
technologists and get excited about
future technologies but very often over
the last 20 years I have watched this
ecosystem get way too ahead of itself
without realizing that the consumer was
not ready nobody is home right now
sitting in a VR contraption spending 10
hours a day VR a what we need to do is
be best at what is current how many
people here listen to a podcast raise
your hand raise it high look around now
put your hands down how many of those
people that just raise their hands were
not listening to a podcast just five
years ago raise your hands
that is what I spend my time on where
are we now not four years from now not
four years ago right this second and
right this second we sit in an
incredible place with audio we value
time and convenience over everything as
much as the world wants us to continue
to value privacy every day humans around
the world give up privacy for time speed
and convenience it's just the way we are
as animals in that insight you must
understand how important your audio
strategy is going forward how many
people here consume
YouTube videos raise your hand recent
high if you do just reach die
how many of you now when you watch
youtube videos are starting to not even
watch the video you're just listening
raise your hands
look around keep them up look around
this my friends between podcast growth
between the fact that the number one
video platform in the world is now being
consumed for a shocking percentage in
audio not video is very important you
can imagine when I see that many hands
why it gets hard for me to get excited
about video production value when I know
the actual consumption is actually being
done in audio doesn't mean that video is
declining videos growing consumption is
growing because we have devices with us
at all times we don't have to go home
and watch television or the radio I
believe that the number one opportunity
for the majority of this room is a very
strong strategy around podcasting and
audio content especially because what
has emerged in the last 24 months and
will continue to grow is AI driven voice
devices in our homes I believe that this
is the end of an era where visual and
written creative can establish so much
brand that it preps you for an audio
centric brand warfare I couldn't be more
passionate and push everybody here to
dramatically rev up the content they put
out in the world
[Music]
with your mother to produce volume has
to be put on a pedestal everybody thinks
that if you make a lot of quantity you
can't make quality I think it's the
reverse I think quantity leads to
quality because as you're putting it out
you can listen to what people are
responding to and you can make better
and better content make I think the
number one mistake people are making
when they're a podcast or YouTube is
they're overthinking their content
production and they're not spending
enough time on the stories it's the
stories that people want like production
matters but it's the story at the end of
the day and so more making less thinking
and what if they have already started
but they have no results for example I
don't know they have been doing videos
for a year or two but they have no
result the first three years I did Wine
Library TV nobody was watching
[Music]
so do you think we're leaving the
podcast do you think podcasting is
harder to monetize I think it's hard to
monetize now because the metrics aren't
out but I think like anything else
that's what they all said about social
networks in 2007-2008 attention always
eventually gets monetized when Joe Rogan
inevitably announces that he get paid
100 million dollars to exclusively be on
whatever platform he's gonna go on I
have a funny feeling everyone's gonna be
like wait a minute so I think when Rogen
inevitably does Howard Stern 2.0 I think
you'll start seeing people realize oh
there is something here and I think I
think people are very basic they they
look for a report or a very simple ad
product to make them feel good while
under estimating when tens of millions
of people are paying attention to
something inevitably there's an
opportunity to monetize
Apple's saying we're improving voice I
got it
I believe that if you look at history
it's usually a singular moment a killer
app a singular moment so I believe
there'll be an Alexis skill built that
is so phenomenal that catches virality
that makes everybody go oh crap ie that
you know if you think back to the to the
iPhone whether it was a social network
whether it was Spotify with iTunes
itself I mean I would argue iTunes
itself right you know whether it was
MySpace whether it was tinder for dating
I think there's a moment and I think
it'll be a killer app or a functionality
that catches the National the global you
know ecosystem and the value prop will
become obvious and away we go
remember eBay looking for wide awareness
in the late 90s it was it was beanie
babies that put so many people on eBay I
would say voice will have a beanie baby
R it was pokemons go that peak that
allowed people to even think about where
this is going
I believe there will be a singular voice
moment that will trigger people saying
wait a minute I can do that on that
instead of this where do you see one
cussing headed
and the creation of new employment as
well I mean I think podcasting will
continue to massively grow which doesn't
mean individual shows will grow because
once there's many more shows there's
only so much attention but I think they
will continue to grow and and as far as
new formats I think then the next format
is really skill based audio where we as
humans are interacting with audio where
we're actually doing things through our
voice and a smart device on the other
side booking our plane through alexa
instead of Expedia on your phone Alexa I
want to go to Miami when would you like
to go Thursday between can you look at
my calendar and tell me the cheapest
price and the best time for me to go
that is a far better experience because
it's using information from your
calendar that is much smarter than my
highest paid assistant and is far faster
and that was a very simple example that
is easily done by google home by tapping
into your Google Calendar and tapping
into open web information think about
that think about how fast the answer
would have been done for me whereas that
would have taken a hundred thousand
dollar admin an hour to achieve think
about that production
do you think people will trust that yes
yep
it's just a matter of getting because
it's just a matter of time of course
people didn't like smartphones people
didn't like pagers people didn't like
the Internet people didn't like fax
machines people didn't like technology
people don't like the future inherently
and the ones that do win they like it
when to have no choice
most people are stubborn and don't like
change a hundred percent of course
because they're inevitably good
technologies like there's a lot of
entertainment and utility value in
wearing those glasses and seeing
information you could literally be
looking at me in 20 years and in the
corner of your eye be given information
of my latest thoughts you know you could
I could know who these people are right
now by wearing contact lenses there
could be a bubble above everybody's head
and I can know how many followers they
have what their passions are where they
were yesterday we're gonna like that why
would it oh no because I think cell
phones and and the internet are scary to
our great-great-grandfather you know so
no I don't think they're scary I don't
think anything is scary because that's
been the way you know airplane was scary
a radio was scary a book was scary they
were scary so no I don't think they're
scary I think I think they're just
advancement everything you just said is
super interesting to me based on the
last thing you said
I have ambition to change things you
have ambition to change things the point
where you said people don't see me as
someone is the most interesting part of
your sentence
nobody who's ever changed anything has
pander to what people think
you have to basically close your eyes
and your ears for the next 20 years and
just put out what you want to put out
and then you have a chance of making it
happen but the more you worry or think
or strategize around acceptance the more
unlikely you'll achieve your goal I
believe it and you can do so much more
the second you stop worrying about them
believing you can nobody has ever
believed I could do what I've done
except myself yeah a Jersey boy made it
[Music]
- zooming voice right now for example
you're mentioning recently that instead
of maybe focusing on video people should
focus on podcasts and yes creating audio
content just want to hear your thoughts
of that that is true I believe that a
wild percentage of YouTube video
consumption is actually just audio I
believe that people are walking the dog
working out traveling on a plane and are
consuming audio
I think what's amazing listen a lot of
people consume my content thank God a
lot of those people listen to the video
or a podcast while they're at their desk
working if they had to watch the video
that the Iraq and I make they wouldn't
be able to work at the same time people
are multitasking and I think when people
multitask audio Rises and video declines
that doesn't mean video is dead video is
growing we're consuming more than ever
it just means audio is rising and it's
coming at the expense of non consumption
I believe that or at the consumption of
music instead of audio information so I
think the same person who walked their
dog for 30 minutes every morning either
just took in nature or used to listen to
music now is listening to a podcast
all right let's go yes just one short
question sure let's go let's walk this
one we need your publications as the
main source for getting information
they're not they're not or now they need
to evolve like anything else you can't
be romantic of how you deliver
information it's the information it's
not the distribution to many traditional
media outlets are too emotional about
monetizing on television or print
without realizing that we want to
consume information somewhere else and
so my belief is that journalism is
forever
in play it just needs to be thoughtful
about where it's producing and
distributing its content mission
accomplished boom boom thank you so much
thank you I will take a look at it for
sure you got a brother take care
everyone that a port-a-john
squawk up to the airport especially that
what's that we're really lucky right
yeah worked out go figure
when you go to the former Soviet Union
[Music]